this is joint work with sling SRAM and
Satish Roslin should be around but
definitely it's the new and improved
title from what I sent earlier which is
I which will be part of the talk I'll
talk about some of square certificates
for random tension of norms of random
pencils independent of our work the
results and random tensors were also
derived by or very similar results we
derived by you I'm Lee which I but
Apollo and when cut guru Swami okay so
let me start by just stop fixing the CSP
so let's look at a very simple one so
random Kalyan so here I think of K is a
constant even let's say k equal to 3 so
here the model is I just want to pick
roughly M closest so let's say with
probability M over N include
an equation of the form
so you have variables x1 through xn over
the boolean domain and with probability
M over N for each I 1 through K with
protium already you sample this equation
and include it into your system f sorry
M over N to the K then you expect
roughly M will expect to see roughly M
equations and here we'll be looking at a
regime where this is sort of
uninteresting for statistics and
probability it's very interesting the
regime where m is much larger than n so
you have more than much more than n
equations think of em as n log n so
clearly in this regime there are no
solutions so there's nothing to study in
terms of the solution space so what are
we doing here our goal here would be to
so in fact something stronger is true in
this regime please in this regime every
assignment satisfies roughly half the
equations no assignment satisfies more
than half the equations so in this goal
will be to certify that in this given an
instance from this distribution we want
to prove or certify that no assignment
satisfies more than half the equations
so
certify an upper bound on the number of
equations satisfied by any assignment so
if this notion of certificate is a
little bit confusing you can instead
think of a related model here the
problem is distinguish between so you
have either a random Kalyan instance or
I will give you an instance with a
planted solution planted instance where
say planted instance is obtained by this
fixing and assignment that you want to
be the planted solution and then each
time you pick an equation you make the
equation consistent with this assignment
with probability 0.9 and a random bit
with very many problem C you're given a
system of equations it's either a random
instances you've no assignments as I've
got more than half or it's a planted
instance where you're guaranteed that
there is some assignment that actually
satisfies in 0.9 fraction of the
constraints and you want to say which is
which and essentially that's what if you
have an algorithm for that you
essentially have an algorithm for the
certification problem and vice versa
so you can think of either of these as a
problem
so what is known about this so this is a
fairly well stated problem right and so
if the number of equations is really
large so if the number of equations is n
to the K over K over to more than n to
the K over 2 then there's a there's a
sequence of works which gets which can
actually distinguish between these two
or solve the certification problem using
a spectral approach so the spectral
approach was I think initiated by go
ahead and cleverly which and then I
think for Kalyan the latest work is by
Alan O'Donnell wit mother and Barak and
Moira so they get they can do this so
for example if k equal to 3 if you have
any more than n to the three-halves
equations then you can construct a
matrix and compute its largest
eigenvalue and that will be a
certificate that there is no good
solution in particular in this case you
can distinguish between the two cases
okay and so nothing is known no
poly-time algorithm known for m less
than n to the K over 2 and in fact it's
believed that this problem is hard for M
less than n to the K root there it's a
sort of a very closely a cryptographic
hardness assumption called learning with
errors it's also this assumption has
also recently been used to prove very
strong very beautiful hardness results
for learning half-spaces so it's a
really nice problem and for me I really
like this problem because it's the
easiest way I know to generate a really
hard computational problem then just
create a planted instance
and it's it's you know it's a really
hard complex problem you know the
solution but the other person doesn't
it's really it's empirically also very
hard computationally so not just in the
worst case okay so what is our visit so
a result is of course we don't get any
anything close to Polly time algorithm
but we show that if you use the sum of
squares algorithm you can refute in
strongly refute instance of random
Kalyan in sub exponential time so in the
following sense so if you give you pick
any Delta
if you give me or I just write the
result and maybe then I've there exists
a degree n to the 1 minus Delta sum of
squares
refutation a strong definition if the
number of equations M is bigger than n
to the K over 2 minus 1 times 1 minus
Delta plus 1 so but one way to think of
this is a phone line so if I just gave
you a linear number of clauses if I gave
you know 100 N equations we believe this
problem is exponentially hard if I gave
you n to the K over 2 equations there is
a poly time algorithm and what we get is
exactly the linear interpolation between
the two so in 2 to the N to the Delta
time you you go 1 minus Delta fraction
of the gap between K over 2 and 1 so
it's exactly the linear interpolation
between the two and say what the sum of
squares refutation is just think of it
you can also think of it as a spectral
algorithm will construct a matrix we
will show that if you compute the
eigenvalues of this a matrix of size and
2 to the n to the 1 minus Delta it will
certify that the value of the linear
system is small and if this actually
matches the SOS lower bound of grigoriev
and shown back
Gregorio and showing back both
independently have showed lower bonds
for sum of squares degree four refuting
this instances and this exactly matches
that up to logarithmic factors switch
places
Thanks so it was yeah
if you said Delta equal to zero you
should get the Polly time algorithm if
you say Delta equal to one you get a
very dumb exponential time algorithm and
for every Delta in between okay and so
this is just for Kalyan but you can ask
the same question about other CSP smooth
particular random case at or random any
other CSP and
once you get a result for random kaylynn
for all K you can use a very well-known
connection reduction to actually show
that you get strong reputation for all
CSPs so basically rather you get a
similar result for all CSP
so forth reset the fourth reset you
expect any assignment such we're awfully
7/8 of the constraints and what this
shows is that if you have n to the 3
half classes you can certify in poly
time in you know and you get a into the
3 half minus Delta you can certify in
time to go into the Delta is it clear
okay so now
it's another
that's
so I guess in terms of running time I
should emphasize that if you have a
degree D sum of squares refutation you
can find it in time two to the N to the
D so yeah and so so sorry
n2 they just entered it it's n to the D
so therefore you can okay so this
related question which is a four
trillion and here the input what you
have is just a tensor it's a k
dimensional array of numbers so for this
you know i for notational convenience
i'll actually use k equal to four so you
have a four dimensional tenth area of
numbers and you can think of this as a
polynomial and the injective tensor norm
tensor is just the largest value of this
polynomial in the unit ball
says so this is the injective tensor now
and the related problem here is suppose
I gave you a random tensor
suppose T is a random plus/minus 1
tensor say every entry is iid plus minus
1 what you can use a simple Union bound
show that these injective tensor norm is
at most square root n for a random
that's a with high probability
you know concentration so you know that
the if I give generator and tensor it's
tensor the maximum of this polynomial is
upper bounded by square root n the
question is what can we efficiently
certify meaning what upper bound what is
an upper bound that we can easily
compute it's always a correct on every
instance meaning on every tensor the
upper bound should be that you know it
should be up at most it should be at
least the it should be valid upper bound
and the spectral injected and Sonam and
on the reasonable fraction of random
instances you want it to give you a good
good value it's oh I'm sorry
our to the end
Thanks yeah it's a Kate answer which is
which is my K dimensional array of
numbers and each dimension is n and here
again you can ask look at a planted
model where I take a tense I take a
vector V look at wheat and said K okay
so this is just a rank one tensor then I
add random Gaussian noise to the entries
so it's a planted model which is similar
to the model here and the question of
certifying is exactly the same as
distinguishing this model was called the
spiked model and the montreuil and
others I've studied this in the past so
yeah the question is what what's the
best upper bound we can certify
okay and we obtained a similar trade off
result between this spectral and the the
exact upper bond so for example for k
equal to 4 the actual value of the
injective 10 Sonam is roughly square
root n but if you use there is a
spectral upper bound which I'll just
talk about soon this is a spectral upper
bound and just denote it by this will
clear what this picture is this up this
is a roughly n so this is something you
can efficiently compute in polynomial
time and it will tell you that it will
tell you that the value is certified the
values at most N and what we show is
that you can get a trade off exactly
like this between these two numbers so
in time n to the Delta you can certify n
to the 1 minus Delta 2 so it's exactly
this
looks like I will finish quickly okay
it's good
yeah so the talk is most of talk is
really simple stuff so please stop me
from unclear any point it's it's really
okay so for the less you talk I'll
actually just concentrate on this
problem okay so you have a random tensor
for random for tensor which has plus
minus one i ID entries and you want to
compute an upper bound of the value of
this okay so what's the natural way to
compute upper bound so firstly you know
we have this polynomial P of X is this
the one natural thing to do is this is
an end to the for tensor n by n by N by
n tensor you can flatten it into an N
squared by n square matrix so this is
the same as I can write this as vector
of length N squared sort of applied to
this N squared by n square matrix
and this notation about I mean is this
tensor has four coordinates or four
modes I care and by this notation I mean
that I flattened this tensor into a
matrix by actually taking the first two
coordinates as one side and the other
two corners to that side okay so this is
just equality so clearly this
immediately implies that okay since X is
unit vector if X is unit vector X tensor
2 is also unit vector so the so or
alternately this is just at most the
spectral norm unit vector X this is at
most the spectral norm of this matrix
so this just take the tensile flattening
to n square by n square matrix and you
compute the just the largest eigenvalue
of the spectral norm of this matrix it
gives you an upper bound on the value of
the polynomial T this is the spectral
algorithm and note that this is just
what is this this is just an N squared
by N squared
iid plus minus 1 matrix and therefore
it's it's eigen values are roughly N and
you get that spectral bomb ok so we
should do something different now okay
otherwise the talk would be over now so
what should we do so what we'll do is
we'll just take this thing and tensor
every every component and take the K
through so let's just take this equation
and tensor every component so you get X
tensor 2 K right and then you take the
tensor of this matrix I'm using K for
both yeah this case let's forget that
this K was there
we're never going to deal with the K we
had always for the rest of talk we're
talking about four tensors and we are
going to use this because or it could
use a different thing here
so I'm took the ten separate of this
every component of it so then the number
becomes the Kate power of the number and
then I can take one over K so this is
exact equality so far okay so now again
you know you could just say this is a
unit vector this is unit vector tensor
possibility work unit vectors so this at
most the tenth you could say that this
is the thing but that would be sort of
you counter-productive me useless
because the spectral norms also tensor
when you tensor so this is useless
okay you could just upper body spectrum
of this matrix but here's where we'll do
something different we'll say these
vectors are not just arbitrary vectors
they're Kate tensors of a vector in n
dimensions so I took a tensor of a
vector in n dimensions so therefore they
have symmetries so this is a vector in N
to the 2k it's an end to the 2k long
vector but it has a lot of symmetry
because it has to come out of UI n
dimensional vector tensor K times so in
particular if I permute you can think of
this vector itself as a 2k tensor if I
permute the coordinates of the 2k tensor
it stays the same and the same is true
here right so since we are looking for I
have vectors these symmetries we can
apply those symmetries to the matrix
so here's what I mean
I mean that if I look at this make this
equation this is equal to the same thing
but now I've symmetrized the matrix in
between by all the symmetries of the
vector I'm looking for so I basically I
can pick any permutation by on two K
elements and any permutation Sigma on
two key elements these are the
permutations of the coordinates and I
can apply that permutation to them to
the matrix in between and average over
all such permutations so I'm going to
average the matrix under these
permutations yes I get a different
matrix now right and the hope is that
this will have a smaller spectral norm
so now I'm going to just suffer bound
this by the spectral norm of this
averaged matrix should be tensor K on
the mill on the matrix right just tensor
K not answer to okay
yes thanks
so now this is my upper bound this is
upper bound we're going to use and we
will actually we can first of all
compute this upper bound easily in time
n to the K by just taking the tensor and
computing the spectral now and we'll
prove that this is actually at most in
the case of four tensor it's roughly n
over
you know it's certainly a no okay but in
today we will just say an okay to the
point one okay so basically you see that
as an increase K the amount of
symmetrization I get a better and better
bound than the original thing which we
had so to make it more clear let me just
see let's just look at this matrix and
see how its entries look like for k
equal to 2 if for k equal to 2 this
matrix this matrix is that we call this
M so this matrix M is n to the 4 by n to
the 4 matrix for k equal 2 and if I look
at its entry suppose its entry you know
its look at its entry ABCD comma alpha
beta gamma delta okay an entry like this
before symmetrization it would just have
this entry ta be alpha beta times T C D
Gamma Delta this is the entry that you
would have before symmetrization what
you what you have now is you'll have you
know 4 1 over 4 factorial whole squared
times every possible way in which you
can match these things so you can do ta
be alpha gamma times P C D beta Delta
and so on so pictorially there are 4
vertices ABCD there are 4 vertices Alpha
Beta Gamma Delta and you draw every
whichever way you draw a four uniform
hyper graph between the two sides you
will get one term here so this is one
term and then you'll get a term like
this sorry
maybe green yeah for every possible
hypergraph Filiberto
all sorts of so that's the entries of
this matrix so that there's polynomials
in the entries of T entries of the
matrix upon rows increase of T and but
you can see that see why this sort of
symmetrization should reduce the norm
intuitively what's going on is if it was
a random tensor these values don't
correlate with each other they don't
obey these symmetries that the X will
hashed has to obey and therefore this
average when you do this averaging it
will reduce the word so it'll reduce the
end even entries go down but in fact the
spectral norm actually decreases so
that's the goal now the goal now is to
prove that if you take a random tensor
and you compute this matrix its spectral
norm is small
any questions so far okay so
so we do the fairly straightforward
approach to bounding the spectral norm
what's this the straightforward approach
is to just use trace method so the idea
is okay we want an upper bound the
spectral norm of this matrix M okay this
matrix M or an upper bound spectral norm
but since spectral norm is hard to get a
handle on we'll just use the expected
trace of
of a high power of the matrix as a proxy
so you know this is a definitely upper
bounded by this and if you pick L to be
like log n d log and in this case or
just say log n log n this is actually an
approximate equality okay so sorry yes
oh yes thanks this is one over two so
it's really now the left hand side was
hard to handle the right hand side is
still pretty complicated but it's still
just this is a polynomial and we can
compute expectations of polynomials
easily okay so that's so we are going
now would be to try to compute the
expectation expected trace of mm
transpose hole to there okay so
so let's just unravel this expectation
okay firstly just to get get a get
ourselves grounded em it is n to the 2 K
by N to the 2 K matrix just so that so
therefore if you take this express and
you expand it out it looks like you know
I pick
the trace is going to the trace is going
to be the sum over all possible cycles
of length L of inside this matrix if I
take and so you this is a a length L
cycle you know a length L cycle in mm
transposes you know product of L terms
like mei bi bi air plus one so so this
picture is a way to think about it so I
have one term for every n to the so
every choice of these sets from n to the
2k so this is a this is the expected
trace so of course I should lose the
expectation okay so now ok what's the
main thing now you know how does this
look like so now I can write this M
itself as a polynomial in the t's right
every entry of M is a polynomial in the
t's okay so the this entry of them is
going to be a four uniform hyper graph a
random for uniform hyper graph between a
and B I so it's very straightforward
simplification this is what happens
this is just going to be some over all
terms of this type so what do you do you
use first write down the
so so it's a sum over you stacked a
tuples to K tuples L times okay this is
some over that and then once you stack
the two K tuples you pick a random hyper
graph between them and then you get a
term for that
okay so this is a fairly straightforward
just that it looks a little bit more
complicated
when you write it out but okay so now
this just becomes the probability that
the hyper graph is evil
the key is that since HP each entry of
dents is a random plus minus 1 will take
expect if it only survives every edge
appears if if and only if every edge
appears an even number of times so
therefore the only terms that survive
here are those in which the high prices
appear even number of times and
therefore the this summation simplifies
to this following calculation so it's a
sum over all tuples in n to the 2k so
you just stack vertices like this and
then you pick a random hyperedge the
random hyper graph like like this
between the parts and then you ask
what's the probability that this hyper
graph is even over the choice of these
red edges right once I fix these
vertices this these vertices are labeled
with some numbers from 1 to N and once
you pick the red hyper edges it will
either turn out that every high pressure
P has an even number of times or not and
that gives you a probability that the
high pressure is evil
- graph is even a sum this over all
possible assignments of vertices
that every hypergraph the every
hyperedge appears an even number of
times yeah so these these vertices are
labeled right from 1 to 7 some from
element at the end you have this picture
we have 2 K 2 L M elements a 2 K
elements here you label the vertices
from values in M and then you pick a
random hyper graph you look at the
probability that every edge hyperedge
appear appears in even number of terms
and you add it up that's what you get
so this is what we need to bound now it
looks a bit nasty but it's actually not
that bad at all
so so I don't know if I'll get to the
end of this calculation but I want to
state pokken problems before I embark on
this calculation so the I mean I guess
the most stark open problem here is the
we don't know how well you can
approximate the norm of a tensor or even
a random tensor we don't have sum of
squares lower bounds
we don't have computational lower bounds
which are strong enough for example the
following is still a possibility I give
you a random four tensor in n to the log
n time or n to the log squared n time
you can get a PETA's for it snow which
is seems unlikely but we don't know
hardness even in the worst case let's
even the worst case I give you a 4
tensor can you approximate its norm
within one we get a PETA's in time n to
the log square and we control this so
it's really should be a really hard
problem but we don't have good hardness
for it and it's related to many other
things like 2 to 4 norm and computation
and it's way quantum to prove games
while approximating the value of quantum
to pure games so it's it's a very
central problem for which we don't have
good harness
it's a good question so this is actually
just a spectral algorithm you could say
it's a suspect logarithm when you go to
see SPS you actually have to we could
you have to sort of not look at this
entire matrix or a case we don't know
how to prove it using this entire matrix
you have to pick a sub matrix of this
and computed spectral norm because the
the key difference between csps and over
here is over here we have no
normalization the entries of X so all
the entries of X the only normalization
have is that the totals to norm is at
most one in three Lin random trillion we
want all the entries to be within one
minus one and for that yeah reason you
need so so even over there you could
describe a spectral algorithm which just
picks us up my sub matrix of this matrix
and computer spectral norm the reason to
describe it as sum of squares is just
for compactness but in the cell you
could describe it easily in just this
way I just a compact way to describe in
the DL the result it's just a compact
way to state the result
right
okay anything other questions really
wanted me to get into this okay and
state and say you at the high level what
this is how this unwieldy expression
goes away okay sir in two minutes okay
so it's really not that unwieldy the
idea is just that when you sample these
hyper edges let's not do it all at once
this seems a complicated process let's
first sample them matching between these
parts let's just first sample edges
between them before we sample high
pressures these green edges then you
could ask the question what is this
quantity
this quantity is actually now you just
sample edges so this is if you look at
random matrix theory this is exactly the
kind of things you count and you can get
way very good estimates on this okay so
now the next step you do is you look at
each layer look at the edges and you
group them into hyper edges you make red
have a hyper edges by grouping these
green edges so and then what you expect
to happen is even if the edges of your
even number of times because it grouping
randomly the hyper edges won't be even
with good probability in fact you know
you in a typical configuration where
every edges even number of times every H
appears roughly two times so it's just a
unique partner with whom if you pair it
map and create the hyper edge it will be
even otherwise it'll beep right so the
probability that the hyper graph is even
given that the edge is even is really
small and you get a factor of 1 over K
to the K pork the L because we went in
such places here look so this is it so
these two this gives you exactly the
bound that you get if you didn't do any
averaging and this helps you get an
improvement over the bound or that block
which depends on K it's exactly if you
take the KL throat of this you get K
I think
yeah it works production matrices yeah
yeah but not in a clean way we don't do
it in the right way we do we just say
that if you pick a random gosh intense
air every entry is at most log n that's
not the right way to do it but for any
C's 4mc species if this that's just a
boundary point on yep the same the the
Scimitar Isaac yeah it's essentially the
same this a you to pick a subpart of
this matrix the thing that goes wrong
with random c ESPYs is the random
variables are much worse behaved than
plus minus one here these are plus minus
one and go to gosh and it's likely will
well ill behaved but if you go to random
CSPs every entry is zero with very high
probability one or plum minus one with a
very low probability it's much less well
behaved so you're actually worried about
a hyper edges appearing not just even
number of times but like five times
gives you a much larger value than one
the higher moments matter and but yeah
there's a hack to just look at the
subject there's a way to look and submit
texture
it's just that you sort of want to avoid
tuples where the same value appears too
many times because that sort of blows up
the moment basically suppose one on one
okay then it's essentially all these
hyper edges are either appear all
together of all not sort of that's the
event you want or it so you actually
look at the sub matrix where this is
multi linear almost not linear meaning
everywhere label here in every tuple
every label appears at most log n times
it's basically typical you want to just
look at a typical
it's rougher
other questions